This man wants a ban on the Quran
and to shut down all mosques
and he could be about to lead the Netherlands.
He's been called the king of Islamophobia by critics
but far right here.
Vildes won the most votes in the Dutch general election
and immediately promised to cut immigration
and what he called the asylum tsunami.
He's anti Islam and his anti migration
and its complete shift to the right for the country.
His election pledges also included plans for DEXY,
a referendum on the Netherlands leaving the EU.
But it says comments on Islam
that have been the most controversial,
saying he wants a de Islamization of the Netherlands
and no mosques and no Islamic schools in the country.
In 2,009 he was even banned from coming to the UK
because his opinions threatened community harmony
and public safety.
However he needs to form a coalition to take power
so he might have to tone that down
if he wants to do a deal.
A left wing
Labour and green alliance came second in the polls
so you may have to turn to them.
Quick off the Mark to congratulate him
was Hungary's right wing PM
Victor Orban
posting this
saying the winds of change are here.